biden
charity spent zero on research 3.7
million dollars on salaries charities
set up after bo biden dies
first reported by the new york post tax
filings viewed
by dailymail.com showed that the biden
cancer initiative amassed 4.8
4.8 million dollars in contributions but
spent three million dollars on salaries
gregory simon who super spearheaded the
obama administration cancer task force
was paired nearly double his 2017
earnings which was 224 thousand dollars
the charity's president received 429 000
in fiscal year 2018 the biden cancer
initiative spent nearly 1 million
dollars on travel and conference
expenses in those two fiscal
years but zero on research how is that
possible you know it's just a bad look
if that's true which it probably is
that's a that's a lot of money to not
spend you know it's a lot of money to
take in but it's not
uncommon in the charity world especially
when there's high profile people that
run charities
i'll give him the benefit of the doubt
that he probably doesn't even know
what's going on with it
but it's an opportunity to take care of
some people like the guy who's making
400 000 to run this thing
i think you have to do something i mean
you're not going to save the world
with 3.7 million dollars with as big of
a problem cancer is
but it would be nice if you could attach
yourself to something especially as high
profile as the death of bo biden was
and as tragic as that was so i think
this is it's a bad look it's a
story but what's worse and what's worse
this or showing trump only paid 750 in
taxes
the filing fee what's worse this or that
for them or the candidate what's worse i
mean
the view because look at look at the way
the viewer looks at it i'm looking at it
from the viewer the voter's perspective
one side here's a guy that's worth three
billion dollars and
he uh paid the you know 750 in taxes the
other one is
here's someone whose son dies creates a
charity raises 4.8 million dollars
and not a penny was spent on research
which ones i can answer that easily it's
way worse for biden and here's why
because his son died of cancer
and and to think that you're not doing
anything go do something else
you know honor him in some way but don't
start a charity for cancer research and
then not do
anything when your son died of that
trump we heard robert kiyosaki break
that down for us last week there's maybe
some loopholes
for guys like him to get around huge tax
bills
so i think this is worse and i would
agree in the fact that
are they buying political favor the
people that donated that money and
there's been no research that's
to me that's fraud weird yeah it's wrong
kind of weird to me by the way
i mean again daily mail uk and new york
post
fair to say they're both extremely
conservative
uh of you know sites they're not fully
left or independent so people have to
know what side they're on it's not like
it's cnn reporting it or msnbc which is
far left
if they do report something like that